un autre aspect du dossier de la
sécurité sociale a été évoqué cet après
midi à l'elysée il s'agit du
remboursement de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse remboursement
promis par le parti socialiste demande
et dans un prochain projet de loi par
des députés socialistes alors que vous
le savez monsieur bérégovoy avait
déclaré au cours de l'été que pour
l'instant un tel remboursement n'était
pas envisagée le mouvement français du
planning familial a demandé cet après
midi des précisions au chef de l'état
sylvie mariant les ivg interruption
volontaire de grossesse seront elles
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
cette question que se pose une majorité
de fou que des délégués du mouvement
français pour le planning familial dont
soumis cet après midi à monsieur
françois mitterrand premier au printemps
par le premier ministre pierre mauroy
remis à plus tard cet été par le
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
solidarité monsieur pierre bérégovoy le
remboursement de lits vg entre-t-il dans
le champ des préoccupations d'automne du
président de la république nous a dit
qu'il qu'il ne disait rien mais qu'il
agissait je peux dire c'est à dire que
le gouvernement prenait ses
responsabilités en vue de je pense alors
ça c'est
une inscription à l'ordre du jour des
débats parlementaires prochain est ce
que le président doit vous sembler comme
monsieur bérégovoy préoccupé par les
familles spirituelles qui serait contre
le remboursement de viger je crois qu'il
a dit qu'il faisait qu'il ne ferait pas
de concessions aux adversaires juste
pour ça que pour les autres choses ou
bien se demander à quoi correspondent
aux changements
l'avis de l'un à l'autre entre le 8 mars
lorsque monsieur roy a fait la promesse
et le mois d'août monsieur béliveau
woerth la retourne arrière
je pense que son propos n'étaient pas de
nous faire part ceux ci pouvaient
laisser problème entre non non non pas
du sol est question que se posent oui
bien sûr et c'est pour ça que nous on a
ri jcb cette promesse on ne serait
certainement pas venu lui demander
maintenant ça va lentement c'est sûr
est-ce que vous avez abordé la déception
de certaines bien sûr bien sûr ça il a
d'ailleurs été très très attentif tout
ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on lui a dit